[Music]
hey yo this is you welcome with me
Marcel Arguello the baddest [ __ ] in
town I have some great guests today
Maggie Mae comedian and she wants a
great monthly show at the York here in
Los Angeles called Plan C and we have J
a great comedian and she also runs a
monthly called pants at the Comedy Store
in Los Angeles California welcome lady
as well thank you yeah feeling right
feeling good feeling good like nothing
like a velvet couch straight on my thigh
you know like I like the sleek here you
got oh thanks it's a new look I'm trying
to go for I love it
yeah I want to like look by but not
aggressive right maybe great yeah
like first time by yeah no you're not it
takes so much gel to do this these are
like that cheap gel like you're those
big types it's a literal jar of gel like
that and it smells like like like Axe
spray like I just smell like a horny boy
[ __ ] I'm really trying to get some
ladies that's in my home yeah amazing
how's that going so far Brad was good to
me oh yeah is there a close-up for every
time I might say something gay something
gay to this camera that's your camera to
be gay Maggie are you feeling you're
looking good okay good cut your pouf out
yeah I'm gonna did this in the car and
I'm not pretty good I love that I was
gonna comb it but then I was like man I
love that I did mine in my car and I
[ __ ] took three hours so just go
that's it yeah that's a lot of work you
should see when it dries how gross that
is just flaky I like looking at people
while I'm putting mascara on I'm like
hey I'm doing this I never do my makeup
in the car cuz I'm doing all everything
else I'm sewing like eating a burger
masturbating shifting like
I'm the worst I'm the most distracted
driver like if there's a person in the
car it's over like I have to focus
do you ladies get road rage yeah do you
yeah you'd stranger yeah really I'd see
you sex me as not you
I scream at everybody nobody in LA knows
how to drive that's true really cuz
everyone's driving like they don't have
anywhere to be that's the problem with
everyone yeah right like that's life
wait what did you call us earlier the
malnourished club oh yeah this is an
advertisement for oh we need to eat more
yeah we're all freezing right now I
don't know if you saw this online but
there was this really cool graphic that
went viral and it was Leonardo
DiCaprio's graph of girlfriends and
they're all under the age of 25 every
girl he's every date is under the age of
25 and then first of all went viral
because it's a hilarious ridiculous
image but also people were debating you
know is that a reasonable cuz I don't
know how old he is 67 he's been in every
movie since I've known I don't think
it's that creepy but I think what it is
is it proves that he's bad at sex I know
right is that it's like in the graph
it's just like a clear indicator that he
keeps getting older and they keep
staying the same yeah it shows like no
progression or evolution on his end yes
like maturity physically and mentally
bizarre but also all the girls are so
hot right there all Victoria's Secret
models they're all models yeah and then
you look back at like when he was like
when he looked like kind of like a hot
chick remember that era of like Jonathan
Taylor - yeah DiCaprio and he was like
dating actresses about yeah like he
something shifted yes once you have a
supermodel you can't go back to a
regular girl with structure he's like
the only pink I want and models yeah
ages strange like I dated a younger guy
and it's fun for a second but it does
get to a point where like I agree yeah I
did a younger guy and it was I was like
we have nothing to talk about you're
dumb okay here's the thing I'm dating a
younger guy right now
oh yes he is 28 older than 20 he's
mature like he's really mature like he
had a like a rough childhood
naturally I raised him said like if you
didn't have a restroom yeah he didn't
see me I think that Liana has also seen
some things right I think that some some
things happen also when you're child
actor where you kind of become repressed
and you didn't stop there like you
stopped maturing at that whatever age
like he hid fame really really early on
and I think he's kind of stuck in that
age that's interest like when he was
like in his 20s and like the very prime
of like Eating Gilbert Grape was with
like when he was like in his 20s I think
that's he's just stuck there like I just
feel like a lot of times the reasons why
they like get new girls lean you know
within a year or whatever when they hit
25 or whatever his situation is is that
they're not challenged any longer so
they go back to what they know they just
get a new one they do the same old game
they do the same old routine and then it
works that settles them for a little
while but then the girls start asking
questions and then Leo's like yeah I
don't I think yourself go for a 35 year
old man want
immature women because it makes them not
feel stupid you know right murder yeah
right smart right like they said like
Elvis wanted like younger women so they
wouldn't make fun of him yes cuz they
didn't know any better right right I
wouldn't read something about leo and
like there was like speculation that he
was dating Claire Danes then I read
something and she was like oh hell no
she found him irritatingly immature
really he was 22 she was 16 playing
pranks on everybody and this is not cute
and he thought she was uptight I love
this 1990s Gus I know I love romeo
giulia gosh oh that soundtracks still
good
movie was great but it yeah it's
interesting cuz I don't necessarily
think it's like intelligence and
maturity I think he like literally like
is stuck in that time like I don't know
I can I couldn't do it don't you get
bored also the girl that he's dating
currently is one of the most beautiful
people I've ever seen
yeah but the girl he's dating currently
has someone he knew the girl he's dating
currently is someone he knew as a baby
so that's weird creepy intro
wait what does he call them pedophiles
get women ready for me roommate roommate
yeah I mean I thought the parents were
grooming her for Leo that is really sick
we have you girls every day to the man
who is older than you too old for you no
but I love emotionally unavailable right
now and I'm scared he's gonna come up on
my on my a dating app so you not need ID
the guy that was over 50 and that was a
nightmare and it was I mean that's why I
think where I got the bad sex idea but
the thing is the girl like a young woman
is gonna be great at sex either that's
to me that's why it's kind of a good
match because the minute the girl starts
figuring out how to make herself calm
fingering out we have those expectations
of our partner yeah and then Leo's like
I'm not gonna make you [ __ ] [ __ ] but
yeah users know what he's making these
great just come write this I feel like
there's God they're coming I mean
they're coming in other ways she's late
actually come watching themselves on the
mirror like oh my god good she's like
we're going to the mom they don't know
they don't know tight app they don't
know any of his like earlier works and
maybe there is something to that that's
refreshing to him oh that they're not
like these huge cuz he's like a famous
person now but he's not like really as
relevant as I mean he used to be like
the guy right right and so like there's
something to at worst like it's
refreshing to not I feel like if they're
not familiar but they know he has money
he's cool with people wanting him for
his money right like he's just fine with
that yeah I mean when you know that's
part of the reason people are drawn to
you I mean that's gotta [ __ ] with your
head on but that's something that's like
that's why it's almost probably
refreshing if like a celeb
meet someone who's like who are you and
they're like you know maybe get to know
them for the real them yeah but how they
doesn't exist anymore well but yeah but
how how fascinated that can a 22 year
old be with his old guy I don't know I
mean he's lived a lie he's probably
travelled he's probably very cultured
like his house is probably sick I don't
know is anybody who really wants a daily
or an article I have had a couple
friends who have had interactions with
him and said that he does have like a
magnetic glow to him in person like
where they're just like uh also I don't
know Titanic I was like a really big fan
of satanic so I would date anybody for a
while you know they have money like that
never let him [ __ ] me I'd be like next
month baby next month you need to do
that Sephora how do you do that don't
you like don't you wanna I I mean I [ __ ]
up a first date yeah me too and I want
to get it if it's not good I'm not gonna
we're not gonna know well here's the
thing if I don't want to [ __ ] me then
that's something he doesn't get to get
I'm denying a man something then I come
off of that I go home and I went yeah I
couldn't try this yes like I go right
away cuz I'm just warning you no no try
it now I eat before I go to the day I
show up to that date on my second met
already a lot of people give that advice
to men about and drink it off before
they go on a date but I've never heard
that for a woman and yeah that's
actually great great that's great advice
because then you're nice and relaxed and
you're ready to just go to Sephora and
just right yeah yeah yeah
is this a quarry trip you also get men
to myself how do you do that I want that
you just make them act like you're like
oh you know I want this I bet you can't
afford it and they're like guys laughs
in that love
ladies yeah tell their man I bet you
can't afford it I bet you can't get me
this car don't take it too far like I
told you we met here I'm a barista I'm
25 there's an ex who paid to get Tyler
Perry's attention on a billboard and
Tyler Perry himself shared it I have his
what he wrote on the on the caption on
he shared it on Instagram and still I
believe it's still up its up he said so
here's the deal this is not the way to
get my attention and she's like oh I
don't even know her name blah blah
you're next
actress you're next mr. Tyler Perry
bubble blah is your next leading actress
yeah with her picture and the picture
solid solid head solid solid and he said
so here's the deal this is not the way
to get my attention if you're looking
for a role one of my shows please don't
do the save your money this is a third
time someone has done this please stop
to audition is free I'm sure you can use
that money for a better purpose acting
classes [ __ ] yeah I love that you want
to work with me and I love that you
invest in your stop when you do things
like this it puts my team on high alert
and makes me look at you sideways you
crazy [ __ ] and I know he said yeah yeah
come on oh I don't know I was like wow
that's really he's like I have no doubt
you'll make it one day god bless you but
don't do this it's not [ __ ] crazy
it's so desperate it's like I'm sorry
what's what it's the opposite of like
playing hard to get
they can smell it on you yeah when I
really want an audition I am NOT gonna
get that [ __ ] unless I'm perfect for it
right right right
you can smell the desperation other
people like but then again a big
spectacle like a big like I don't know
if your dad's works yeah should make it
on Ellen I mean what does that billboard
prove about your acting abilities act
yeah just proves that you know how to
Google how to get a billboard if you're
bad with money yes she has two kids kids
two kids one of which is a tan infant oh
my god she's
I mean it's just maybe she talked one of
her dude she's not [ __ ] into buying a
billboard I bet you couldn't afford a
billboard for that she go funded her
billboard she got a GoFundMe for it but
still you can't
apropriate that money that's wild
what's the crazy thing you might you
both have ever done to get someone's
attention when I first moved out to LA
there was this catering company called
the two dudes and there was a show about
it on the Food Network and I was like
when I come out there I'm just gonna
straight-up call and get a job because I
had a lot of bartending experience
working and I called and they're like
how did you hear about it I was like you
guys just sort of like really close to
my house gaming companies near my house
and then we became friends I worked for
them for years they now open that
restaurant animal hmm but yeah I like
totally like back and slid into their
kind of a thing before DM was a thing
and yeah I don't know it's like I feel
like if you put it out there and you
really want to do something or not like
sign me about you know like you went a
little weird I just like straight-up
called and was like hi like you know but
that's like you call places where you
want to work yeah that's not out of the
realm of like you didn't put up a
billboard Lake hey guys here's your next
new caterer I know that guys yes dear
catering companies I'm your next leading
caterer tired I mean I think the wildest
thing that I ever did to try to get an
acting gig was when I lived in Texas
I drove me and my friends drove to an
audition in Louisiana which is kind of
dumb like your American Idol what was I
did say American eyes yes can you say no
Islam yes do it
I got bronchitis
American Idol I'm here I ended up a
picture on their website that's amazing
yeah like page but intensely have you
done a cattle call have you guys any
cattle haul I used to do with them all
the time when I first got out oh oh yeah
actually go to all of them
stand up men BC I did a cattle call oh
yeah that was right of the Improv yeah I
sell for hours and that line too yeah
like the very beginning is that [ __ ]
good for me good for you I do like
audience work it was eight hours of
sitting in this audience work for $64
but I would meet everybody like I was
one of those people that's like and and
your energy yeah you know and I think I
don't know it's like yeah you got to put
in your dudes like I'm a big believer
and that's why it pisses me off that she
would do something like this cuz it's
like you're trying to skip those paying
deuce yeah and they're like you're like
everybody else is working their ass off
and you're just like everything to the
front of the line many levels yep I
agree I got a bunch of followers to send
me questions thank you for sending
questions okay thank you so much for
future submissions please email you
welcome questions at gmail.com ask us
whatever you want we're gonna be happy
to answer them so I picked three
questions for you ladies for us so the
first question is what do I do if I'm in
love with my ex who's now my best friend
again I don't want to make things messy
like they were during our breakup
ooh that's so much to unveil a but are
you still in love with them or you still
with in love with the idea of what you
guys used to be or like are you just in
love with being friends with them
because some of these people and their
friendship they work better than you
know bringing sex into the equation it
messes everything up I like have a big
believer i don't believe that i don't
because i still have friendships with
people that I've had sex with and yeah I
was actually hoping that it would brew
in the friendship and it didn't
I'm gonna put the friendship out of you
you're not gonna want to be my friend
after we [ __ ] yeah it does make me
wonder if they are confusing their
romantic feelings with like their
friendship feel it you don't mean cuz I
do as friends we can love each other and
it feels like a romance of its own you
know but I think that it's kind of be
confusing when you don't know and you've
already had their relationship with you
have you ever been in a situation like
that yeah I'm in a similar situation now
with like not like as it wasn't a
relationship with someone I was having
sex with them kind of having sex with
again and I think what is important to
figure out is like what do you want out
of it mmm like are you wanting to ask
them just to see what their reaction is
because you know sometimes when you like
feeling sad and you want to and you text
someone to get happy it's like a
codependent kind of behavior or like you
want to see what their reaction is and
you're waiting to see what they say
already figure out what you want before
you approach them yeah I just think oh
people are friends they forget that
their exes for a reason
mm get it you guys didn't work out for a
reason people do you know they they
they're different yeah people can grow I
do agree with that but if that's the
truth then that means give it five years
and see how you feel then yes yes give
it some time yeah yeah cuz I feel like
people get lonely and then they start
remembering the good times and they
start remembering how this person
validated them and oh okay I remember
that the time we went to Catalina and
this and that you know - I think a lot
of people are it's hard to make good
friends maybe they're just having a hard
time with their other friendships and
then they lean on this other person that
they rely on and that kind of
complicates things in their heart but
what are they missing like what is it
sex is the only thing that that's not
happening now is sex yeah that one's
gonna say but I don't know what to tell
you get wrong self-esteem get on Raya
all right next question what would your
advice be to women who want to develop
the kind of self-confidence that you
demonstrate oh thank you wait did you
just put that in there as a compliment
to yourself oh look first of all every
word three questions okay but what I
will say is I chose this question for
you two ladies because you both have
great self self-confidence
Wow I love that you love yourselves and
that's like obvious in your social media
and talking to you in lively so that's
honestly why I picked the question not
just because I'm great we all know I'm
great okay how did I get here you know
it's a question we can all answer do you
what how do you feel about that it's I'm
competitive and kind of aggressive so
I'm not about to let anyone's opinion be
more important than what I'm gonna think
like when I moved out here to California
everyone's always like oh wow you're you
know you're eight in here and then you
move to California and you're - it's
like no I'm not about to come out here
and let's send [ __ ] who doesn't
even know how to drive fast make me feel
like I'm less of a person because like
you know my teeth are crooked
I can recognize that I'm self-conscious
about them and I will allow myself to be
like okay yeah
you take the crooked oh I got eyes I can
see that right however I've a lovely
smile yeah that's that's not a thing I
think about you you know what I mean the
things that we have I think that
self-conscious yeah yeah the things that
we have that like weigh us down know
things that other people are thinking
about also everybody is thinking about
themselves like you know right self-love
is a very new thing for me like I would
say like maybe in the last year I felt
like no self-love yeah [ __ ] yeah like
yeah it took me a really long time
that's part of the reason we've been
able to become better friends in the
last year is because in the past I mean
it was really scared of it really I was
I mean it came from my own insecurities
I'm alone it all stems from yourself
it's something that yeah friends with
somebody who is insecure about
themselves and projects that onto you is
the worst yeah that is the worst I can
only really be close friends with people
who love themselves yes I know confident
in themselves because I don't feel like
oh if so
the good happens to me they now hate
that's me I hate that [ __ ] so much
people start hating somebody for
something good right you should be doing
well it's energy it's good energy around
that they're doing well it's not there
they are content with themselves
vibrations are high yeah their
vibrations are high and they're happy
because even I'm like my lowest of like
living out of my car like struggling
like broke as [ __ ] like I was so happy
for my friends and and I was so happy
with myself like because that [ __ ]
doesn't it's not how I value myself you
have to believe and love yourself at
whatever that means which is like the
most basic [ __ ] but the difference is
for me and I can only speak for myself
I've been this way since I was a kid
like there was no questioning me there
was no putting me down like even when I
started like putting thoughts together
about like massage me because I don't
know misogyny was at 8 years old but I
knew that when my dad said the girls can
do this and something that the boys can
do I was I would push back like why why
is that can you explain to me can you
break it down like mathematically this
doesn't make sense two plus two does
unequal four here you need to tell me
why this [ __ ] is not adding up and which
of course made me a little kind of like
10 years old but I didn't care I love
that about myself like I love that
because I don't question that for really
long yeah I'm sort of going through this
thing where I'm like can I even be
friends with a lot of these people
anymore yeah I see this new like I don't
I have a lot of friends that I realize I
kind of treat me like [ __ ] right and I
love it and that was like an insecurity
thing for a long time like oh if I'm
really myself they're not gonna like me
yeah but like a good exercise that I
found for myself this is like kind of
cheesy very la but like for yourself
watch the negative things that you say
out loud hmm like really catch yourself
when you're putting yourself down like
especially about your physicality like I
look like [ __ ] today like write it down
like don't say something like and then
just try to never say some negative
things about yourself out loud it's like
just an exercise yeah just try it for
like if you do it's also the opposite is
also true is like even even now and I
live alone like I'd catch myself like I
walked past and I'm like look good I
said I love you
yeah and it's not even something that
I'm even if someone was or wasn't there
I would still say it all out to myself
because it's it's what I believe to be
true even if I look goofy as [ __ ] I
don't care cuz goofy is cute too like oh
yeah you got to love yourself for what
you are and even if you're trying to
improve yourself and the other key is
surrounding yourself with people who are
gonna support you and uplift you and
aren't gonna say well [ __ ] to try just
not saying negative things I'm saying
only positive things about yourself for
two days literally two days like all
right here's the last question other
than sex what has kept you in a bad
relationship oh that's a question
actually that you know what that low
self-esteem love stuff that's who's kept
me in a bad relationship
mine was socially we were very well
known as a couple oh and we host it and
we like hosted a lot and my interesting
I was scared of like how it would break
my community and like and the friends
that I would have to divorce I wonder if
that's what Beyonce thought probably
it's probably hard it's like hard when
you know when you're known socially as a
couple like think about all the friends
that you have together and then I would
think about like oh I'm not gonna be
friends with this person anymore
like you lose a lot of friends after you
have a break I'm saying I lost a lot of
friends in that sad yeah but like
ultimately you become friends again if I
was supposed to be friends yeah I
realize like my last relationship how
many people just like didn't like me and
we're just like friends of mine because
of him hmm that's good to know yeah
exactly
I cut the fat out yeah yeah what about
you Maggie
I guess I stayed in one relationship
because it was a like it was kind of a
longest relationship I'd had and I was
just trying to make it work for you know
you already put in the time southern
mentality yeah yes I remember telling my
friend okay he's got one week to show me
why I should not break up with him now
he will give him one week to show me why
and I went over to his house the next
day and I saw his face and said We Need
to Talk
I'd rather be alone than unhappy I mean
I know I've lived this long without a
man and like just the older I get the
more I'm like I like Who I am I like
going home and not having to be
accountable to anybody like the whole
this is not working but I'm gonna make
it work
miss me with that [ __ ] like I don't
have time for that anymore you know like
I'm not like you I'd already put in time
so if that's something they're holding
on to it's like let it go
yeah like you can marinate a steak and
then throw it out it's fine fine more
sake it'll get more steak just one day
or Nate's yes or whatever yeah dipping
it in you know when my dad was sick
before he died I was dating a guy it was
casual yeah but my dad was dying and it
was like I was so [ __ ] up in the head
so [ __ ] up emotionally and this dude
was so terrible to me he had no problem
staying around because I wanted to stay
around and it was it was my choice like
I was the one calling and I was the one
coming around but I definitely think
about how like alright that blasted two
years longer that I needed to and it was
just because my dad was dying and I was
[ __ ] with my head and grief is a
[ __ ] like yeah I was with someone when
Brody died like and I stayed with him a
few months because I was like at his
house when it happened and then like
kind of depict like he became this like
make me feel better yes
no I already feel like [ __ ] what am i
doing it so love yourself I think that's
the theme of today yeah that's the thing
you love yourself don't be I don't know
putting up a billboard don't don't
don't beat yourself up if you say the
wrong thing oh so if you buy me dinner
you can impress a welcomed [ __ ] thank
you
subscribe listen to us great bigs I
don't know what else we can reshoot this
[Laughter]
[Music]
you